montana
must
[music]
just haven’t seen such a crowd for a long time
[music] the
Russian army does not occupy
Ukrainian territory
takes all measures to preserve the lives
and safety of
civilians I emphasize that strikes
are only on military targets  and with
exceptionally high-precision weapons
[music]
our servicemen immediately fight
standing with a full understanding of the right you are
your money even after being wounded, soldiers and
officers remain in the ranks, I want to say that a
special military operation is proceeding in
strict accordance with the schedule according to the plan,
all the assigned tasks were
successfully solved
[music]
ours
[applause]
him